rémy raynaud bonjour
bonjour bienvenue sur rt france ce matin
pour commencer peut-être votre
témoignage de professeurs on va le
souvent d'école délabré à max est à
marseille racontez-nous dans quelles
conditions vous travaillez vous et vos
collègues aujourd'hui
bon moi ma situation spécifique je suis
enseignante dans un lycée des quartiers
nord qui hockey a été créé il ya cinq
ans donc en fait il est neuf ça c'est ça
c'est un point positif mais ans c'est un
des rares points positifs qu'on connaît
dans dans la situation actuelle à
marseille sachant que ces lycées neufs
récent mais
qui accueille un public des quartiers
nord
quand on compare les indicateurs ça
correspond à un établissement
d'éducation prioritaire et pour lequel
on n'a pas de moyens d'éducation
prioritaires n'ont pas de moyens
spécifiques pour aider nos élèves et ça
c'est ma situation personnelle dans ce
lycée récent ce qu'on voit aussi c'est
les élèves qui nous arrive arrive de
collège qui pour une partie d'entre eux
sont dans des sites dans des états assez
déplorable aussi et qui eux-mêmes arrive
d'école qui pour une grande partie
d'entre elles bien sont délabrés sont
insalubres il faut pas oublier une chose
c'est que la plupart des trains une
grande partie des établissements et des
écoles marseillaise sont encore remplis
d'amiante avec le danger que l'on
connaît pour les publics et pour les
personnels donc c'est ça la réalité de
l'école à marseille et et c'est une
réalité qui était aussi qui se traduit
aussi par ben en fait des moyens qui ont
aussi réduit qui se sont réduits ces
dernières années et ça peut-être en
proie à y revenir un peu plus tard
puisque moi dans mon établissement on
n'a quasiment plus de moyens pour
dédoubler des classes pour dédoubler des
heurts notamment dans des anglais par
exemple c'est pas une semaine détaille
en histoire géographie voilà et on a des
ça 35 élèves alors on va effectivement y
revenir mais est ce que ça veut dire que
1 milliard d'euros débloqués pour la
rénovation finalement vous nous dites
c'est bien mais ça suffit pas puisque
derrière il ya tout l'accompagnement des
élèves
bah voilà on va pas refuser un milliard
2 voilà mais j'ai cru comprendre que
c'étaient déjà c'était pour les écoles
est une très bonne chose est-ce que ça
suffira déjà pour améliorer le bâti
scolaire rénové relatifs scolaire c'est
une seconde c'est la question dispose
faut se rappeler que en 2003 jean marc
ayrault était venu et avait fait un
blanc marseille également je crois que
c'était au tour de 5 milliards alors
écoles transports et cetera donc ce que
fait manuel macro aujourd'hui dans un
contexte pré électoral c'est pas non
plus une nouveauté ni par la taille ni
par une fan n'est pas historique c'est
pas la première fois que ça arrive la
question c'est quelle transparence des
gens donnent à aux moyens que l'on va
accorder quelle transparence on va avoir
sur qu'est ce qui va être fait et au
delà comme vous disiez au delà de la
rénovation il ya aussi la construction
de nouvelles écoles enfin marseille
c'est une ville qui gagne en une
population est en fait c'est les moyens
humains que l'on met pour accompagner
tout ça il y avait certes et enfin dans
l'est dans les écoles marcel dans toutes
les bouches du rhône on a plus
suffisamment de moyens de remplacer les
professeurs des écoles
et donc il ya des enfants qui se
retrouvent il ya des classes qui se
retrouvent sans enseignants parce que on
n'a pas de poste pour remplacer les
enfants donc c'est pour remplacer les
enseignants excusez moi donc c'est ça
aussi la réalité dans l'éducation
nationale à marseille et et c'est aussi
ça en collège et en lycée m on parle
aussi beaucoup des quartiers nord comme
étant des quartiers réputés dit
difficile est ce que dans ce contexte là
vous demandez également finalement un
ajustement dans l'éducation pour ces
élèves plus de moyens humains aussi
c'est évident que bon voilà les
quartiers nord on entend parler même
quand on n'est pas de marseille c'est
une c'est une réalité où il ya
énormément de classes populaires
d'élèves en difficulté et bien entendu
il faut un bhl en particulier il y avait
des choses qu'on appelait l'éducation
prioritaire notamment en lice et qui a
disparu
il faut des moyens supplémentaires
humain il faut aussi
je pense réfléchir dans la durée comment
on articule les différents niveaux entre
l'école le collège et lycée et tout ça
se réfléchit et tout ça implique des
moyens
et tout ça s'articule à une politique de
la ville à une politique de transport je
vous donne un exemple concret
un certain nombre de lycées
professionnels de marseille sont dans
les quartiers sud mais accueille
majoritairement des enfants des
quartiers dans des adolescents les
quartiers nord qui met une heure et
quart bon allez pour aller sur leur lieu
de scolarité
ce n'est pas ce n'est pas acceptable
donc tout ça doit s'articuler moi je
travaillais dans un essai je vis dans un
quartier nord je travaille dans les
quartiers nord je mets 25 minutes en
voiture si je prônais les transports ce
que fois une partie de mes élèves je
mettrai une heure et quart dans deux
quartiers nord un quartier nord ouais
donc cesser ses global ça va au delà en
tout cas 34 établissements doivent être
détruits et puis reconstruit on imagine
c'est un projet qui réclament du temps
est-ce que
vous a dit comment la transition serait
assurée ce que vous avez des éléments
pour l'instant pour l'instant on sait
même pas enfin rose sait depuis un
certain temps puisqu'il y avait un plan
partenariat public privé sur les écoles
de marseille d'un certain nombre
d'écoles de marseille devait être
détruite et reconstruite
on a refusé on était très nombreux à
refuser ce partenariat public privé qui
était extrêmement coûteux à la fois
d'entretien et qui n'était pas du tout
efficace en termes de services publics
pour information la l'entretien de ce
partenariat public privé devait coûter
quasiment l'équivalent de l'entretien du
reste des écoles donc on espère déjà que
ça ne sera pas du tout sur ces bases là
pour ce faire les relais reconstruction
les rénovations reconstructions et puis
au delà des 34 écoles il faudra voir les
rénovations des nombreuses autres écoles
mais pour l'instant on n'a pas d'élément
on sait que chaque fois qu'il y à des
travaux c'est toujours très difficile
pour les équipes c'est toujours très
difficile pour les élèves
et donc on est inquiet aussi de la
manière dont peuvent se tenir les
travaux parce qu on sait que ça produit
du stress que ça produit des difficultés
et et des désagréments importants pour
les familles et pour le faire pour les
élèves et pour les personnels mais pour
l'instant on n'a pas d'éléments précis
un merci beaucoup en tout cas rémi
raynaud d'avoir accepté notre invitation
ce matin sur rtl france je rappelle vous
êtes enseignant de sciences économiques
et sociales au lycée simone weil dans
les quartiers nord de marseille il vous
est aussi membre du bureau national de
la cgt éducation